one Porsche drive is the leading address
of the luxury German carmaker in North
America Porsche has spent 100 million
dollars to transform an old Ford
assembly plant into an automotive palace
is Porsches largest ever investment
outside Germany the experience center
Atlanta offers a classic car exhibition
driving simulators a performance center
and a 1200 square meter business center
for conferences and events
last month on our current testify no
Dyson over ass why spend 100 million
dollars the ultra-rich can play the
stock market buy a yacht or plane or
build a racing test track but now people
can test out the capabilities of the SUV
or sports car off the regular road and
it brings people one step closer to
buying a car of course the grand opening
of one Porsche Drive attracted
journalists from all over the world
the carmaker expects its new North
American headquarters to attract 30,000
visitors a year Supervisory Board
Chairman welcome parsha
was also there Porsche said that he was
involved and it was a real challenge it
was supposed to look nice but not too
expensive look nice it does as anyone
who has enjoyed the 2.6 kilometer test
track can attest those who have can
hardly wait to get back on it
I thought I know says driving
instruction is always a good idea you
don't just want to be fast but safe too
that starts with things like proper
sitting position and emergency braking
techniques at the same time people
should have fun that's why Daimler are
also building a test center in Atlanta
it's got the busiest airport in the
entire US which makes it easily
accessible from across the country
of course the twenty thousand five
hundred square meter grounds would be
complete without an off-road park if
classic Porsches are built for tight
curves SUVs like the cayenne and the
makan are designed for rough terrain
you might find hotels us that most SUV
owners are proud of their vehicles and
it would be embarrassing if they lost
their nerve off-road here they can
practice so they look good going up and
down mountains we didn't back off onto
them back up five and one Porsche Drive
is hardly the end of the Porsche
experience centers the car maker plans
to build similar corporation attractions
and other parts of the world Porsche
chief executive Matthias Mueller says
the car maker is building a driving
experience center in Shanghai and plans
further ones in Moscow and Istanbul
another in LeMond will incorporate the
famous track releases Porsche hopes to
offer customers something special some
that is fitting the cunning but for now
one Porsche drive is the car makers
premiere bid to make Porsche more
accessible to people around the world